beautiful engagement rings that are not
going to be these high-end three-carat
you know with the whole alphabet they're
listed for what color the diamond is i
mean it's just gotten crazy here's a
spoiler alert uh i forgot my wedding
ring today and i took a sharpie and drew
it on here i thought you got that
tattooed no actually i didn't i drew it
on there just like once a week you just
get a sharpie out and read once a week i
just was on the way to work i was
hustling this morning i had early some
early stuff this morning uh at this
point just get it tattooed i i probably
will it's your next one it's a henna
it's actually that's right oh that's guy
um
george you've you were you've been
married more recently than me was it a
dramatic process
no
no because it wasn't about the ring and
the wedding and we did get a free
wedding because we're ballers and won a
contest but that's just
you know i can't give you advice on that
yeah you don't really get an opinion
then because your wedding was free
that's true but i do have a lot of
opinions about how much you should spend
on a wedding and it should be as little
as possible and more focused on
pre-marital counseling than the wedding
day i like it there you go all right
this is the ramsay show triple 825-5225
give us a shot we'll be here when you
get back
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
colony joined by george campbell we're
taking your calls on money life
relationships mental health anything you
got going on work give us a shout triple
eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to
h town let's go talk to stephen in
houston what's up steven
hey guys how you doing it's an honor to
be on thank you so much brother what's
up
all right so i'm 17 years old i live in
houston texas and for the past year and
a half inspired by y'all i've been doing
my best to stay in work and working a
job at starbucks in various side hustles
i've managed to save fifteen thousand
dollars
way to go man
you got any debt appreciate it
no absolutely none dude you're a rock
star way to go so you got fifteen
thousand dollars saved and no debt and
what is your question today
well the problem is that whole 15 000
sitting in a high school checking
account and uh i've been looking up on
inflation lately and uh it's not looking
so good for it so i was wondering to go
out and advice on it um i've been
thinking about putting my money in
mutual funds and my parents have already
started a roth ira for me and they're
already maxing that out wow i've been
having a hard time investing because my
parents are in the higher income
brackets so i'd have to get 35
basically
uh off the money anytime i dust with
them okay
let's slow down a second stephen what do
you want to do with your life take about
30 off what's the next four or five
years of your life look like are you
looking to
go to college are you looking to go into
the workforce be an entrepreneur what
are you thinking
yes sir i want to go to college um i'm
thinking a m right now they have a
pretty good value and they're right here
in texas but i still see my family
the whole situation i have is my parents
set aside 110 000 for me and anything i
don't spend is mine so i'm looking for a
state school for sure dude you are the
man and your parents have raised you
well
sharp people so here's the thing
i i think you have plenty of time to
invest i have no question you're going
to be a multi-millionaire probably by
your early 30s at the latest and so what
i want you to do right now is invest in
stephen and make sure that we get
stephen through college completely
debt-free and maybe you're going to want
to upgrade in car and maybe you're going
to meet a nice girl maybe you're going
to want to buy a house there's a lot of
life that's going to happen in the next
10 years so i don't want you to throw
all your money into investments in the
name of inflation
absolutely so so it's one of those
things brother you're you are so
ahead of your uh
the people around you that um you found
yourself all alone and you feel like
you're behind and you're not you're way
way ahead
um and george
you can do the math quicker than i can
but
the inflation against your 15 000 is not
it's not going to be make or break over
the next few years right you're not
talking like oh i would have made 10 000
bucks or you know what i mean yeah you
could put it and if you want to put in a
high-yield savings account which will
get you you know maybe a percent and a
half right now which is better than zero
absolutely but again i was thinking
marcus by goldman sachs is that a good
one yeah yeah i use that one and uh it's
great and so that's a good place to park
money but i would not put it into the
stock market into mutual funds it'll
create some taxable scenarios your
money's going to be locked up you might
be selling at a loss i don't want that
for you at 17. when you've got a lot of
life expenses coming up between car
college housing there's a lot of
unknowns right now and so i'd rather you
have a giant pile of liquid cash at 22
than say well i'm broke but i have 100
000 in mutual funds yay
exactly and um that 110 000 looks huge
until you start spending it on college
right so that's a good semester and a
half probably i'm just kidding texas a m
is a great school um but that you're
going to burn through that 110 grand
over four years pretty quickly when you
factor in rent and room and board and
tuition and study abroad all those
things that pop up so hang in there
brother and his parents already have the
roth ira going for him yeah that's 17.
that's exactly right so he'll be just
we're doing great doing great crush
let's go to uh paul in san francisco
what's up paul
hey guys uh i have a question for you
i'm 27 years old um i just recently got
married about a month ago congrats me my
wife for trying to figure out thank you
very much
me and my wife are trying to figure out
the best approach to create fine
financial freedom in our life and our
next goal is to purchase a home
now i live in the bay area and it's
extremely expensive to purchase a home
out here so we're trying to figure out
if we should be putting all of our ducks
in one basket to put you know everything
towards this home or as we're doing now
we're putting some money aside for 401k
for mutual funds and other means of
investments so i'm trying to figure out
should we be splitting it like we're
doing now or should we be trying to put
a lot more heavy load onto the house
side
well i'll borrow this tagline from
reese's there's no wrong way to eat a
reese's and so this kind of applies to
you're wrong way to say it though
george's reese's reese's reese's pieces
that's how i remember it so when it
comes to 3b and baby step 4 which is
what you're talking about do we pause
investing to save up the down payment
it largely depends on your lifestyle
your income your age your future goals
your risk tolerance and so and your
shoes at 27 you guys are pretty young
you just got married uh there's nothing
wrong with investing right now as long
as you're okay
slowing down the down payment process
especially in the bay area which means
it could take five to eight years to
save up a down payment right
right
what's your household income
right now we clear about 200k after tax
which is minimum wage for san francisco
yes well uh
yeah do you guys want to stay there long
term
yeah you know i own a business here okay
um so it's it it would be really hard to
move i would love to get out of this
area honestly but it's just that you
know it just really depends it's it's a
kind of a custom unique business so it'd
be hard to move it somewhere else okay
okay well we usually say if it's gonna
be longer than two to three years you're
pausing investing um that's that's our
limit and so if it's going to be beyond
that i would go ahead and begin
investing beyond that period of time but
if it's for a short period two to three
years you want to pause investing you
guys are young you got plenty of time on
your side you have a great income then
if you want to stack up that down
payment in two to three years because
you have 15 more of your income we're
okay with that too so what would that
look like for you let's say you paused
investing how quickly could you save up
a reasonable down payment for a
reasonable place in the bay area
well the goal would be at least fifty
percent down which is somewhere here is
five to six hundred k um you know
currently we have a 60k emergency fund
which i want to hold there whoa
you know 400 500 k investments so you
know i we could kind of tap into that
stuff but i don't really want to cut my
legs off there so if we didn't tap into
any of that stuff is that non-retirement
investments
all non-retirement you're going to hate
this most of it's in crypto actually wow
well i'm just looking at that pile of
money going hey what if we cashed out
with five hundred thousand dollars and
we fast forward this thing and get out
of crypto what are you doing man
yeah i know i know i know it's uh it's
uh i'm trying to juggle that around too
trust me okay uh you can keep juggling
it or
hang with me here
um you can just like
stop juggling
here's what's really cool about your
situation you could do one of two things
you could take your crypto money and put
it in your front yard and just set it
all on fire which would be cool which is
what essentially you're doing or
um
you could have a house in the next 30 45
days
yeah yeah which would be really nice
so do we want virtually no money you
want pretend money for
like internet money um i have some
friends who have some internet
girlfriends they're not real but like
it's fun or do you want like a real
house that you can put your real body
and family into
yeah the the latter's the obvious answer
is
i guess what goes on in my head is hey
i've made insane growth on my investment
over the last 10 years of doing these
investments and i don't want to you know
it'd be hard for me to cut that off
because you know who thinks the same way
gambler's in vegas right they're like
well i'm doing great i'm going hot at
the crafts table i don't want to kill
the ground i got to go to the bathroom
i'm just going to pee in the bottle
under the table because i don't want to
leave the tape right hey listen um
there's a great nasim till up quote that
i love it says i woke up today
so
i'm either immortal or i haven't died
yet
and you my friend have been playing with
fire
and you think oh i'm just gonna keep
building a bill
there's a point when this comes to a
dramatic and swift end i would suggest
you cut your losses here's another quote
quit while you're ahead
exactly that's a simple
tell your wife it's happening house time
is on me and my imaginary money we'll be
right back
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you that's why you need to get in touch
with churchill mortgage to make sure you
do this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how many times have you found yourself
saying one day
when thinking about a goal you have one
day i'll be able to buy a house one day
i'll be happy with my career or one day
i won't have to battle with anxiety
anymore
stop waiting around
whatever your one day is you have to
start now just start and that's why we
created smart conference smart
conference is the one day event where we
tackle all areas of your life and hey
let's face it we can all use that kind
of boost right now you'll hear from the
nation's top thought leaders on money
career mental health relationships
marriage and leadership george will
probably be wearing a denim jacket again
this event is hitting the road and will
be coming to dallas
dallas texas on saturday october 22nd
event passes are flying out the door the
vip and platinum passes are already sold
out but you can still get general access
passes for 39 bucks best-selling authors
and world-class speakers include rachel
cruz me ken coleman george campbell
christina ellis and uh dave will be
there in full force not to mention our
friends and leadership experts from life
church craig and amy grochelle
we'll have some other big surprises it's
gonna be a blast it's gonna be an
all-day thing make sure you go check it
out visit
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
event passes today all right let's go to
uh amy in boise hey what's up amy
hey guys thanks for having me on thank
you so much for reaching out what's up
um okay i have a three week old baby um
and last week unfortunately my husband
said that he wants a divorce
so
i am
re-re-looking at my life and trying to
figure out what my next move should be
um we have been doing baby step two-ish
for a bit here and i'm gonna be leaving
the marriage debt-free
um
so
my parents have offered to have me move
in with them
um for a time probably until the spring
and i'm just wondering if if that's a
smart move or not
so
the way you're talking about this is
pretty calm and collected
is was this a shock to you or is this a
long time coming
or are you just in shock right now
pretty sure i'm in shock okay okay so
um yeah we've we've struggled we've been
together for 12 years married for four
and and we've really been struggling
he's been really distant
for about a year and
i've just
you know not recognized the pain of my
words so he's essentially just closed
his heart
and
he says we have incompatible trauma and
that's why we are
going our separate ways so sounds like
you're going your separate ways because
he's walking out the door
um
unfortunately yeah i think that's the
case
um guess i just start by saying i'm
sorry
um
a
i grew up in in houston and uh
houston texas and hurricanes are regular
currents there
and it
there was times that we would go in
after a hurricane to come through and
help our friends or neighbors or
community members cleaning up the mess
and sometimes we'd get there soon enough
after
um
the hurricane had hit and the sun comes
up
and
there's people walking around
just rubble
looking for something like a water bill
like i got to get this bill i was
supposed to pay it and i got to figure
it i got to find it and um so i can get
this thing paid
and it was one of those moments where
we had to you have to get somebody to
stop
and walk out into the street and look at
their house because their house is gone
and so what i would tell you is
your husband's throwing a grenade in the
middle of your life
and so right now we're gonna stop
talking thinking about baby step two we
stop talking about the debt-free journey
and all that kind of stuff
what we're gonna do is start thinking
about four walls like do we have a place
that we can go and you said your mom's
reached out i think that's a great idea
um
okay um
making sure that we have a place to stay
we've got food we've got clothes we've
got utilities we've got transportation
let's make sure these basic needs are
met for you and your new new new baby
okay
let's start yeah and i do
and i do have so we live in a town home
now and he's um he's moved out
and i i can afford it by myself
um
but i'm just trying to decide if it
maybe where i would do more healing or
so so here's an important here's an
important move um and this came from dr
andy young the guy who trained me on
crisis response um
don't make any major decisions for six
to 12 months if you can avoid it if you
have to sell this place because you have
to
great um let's do that because we're
again we're going back to
survival do we have the basics right now
um but trying to figure out i mean
you're talking how when did your husband
tell you this
uh last wednesday yeah i mean you're in
the middle of this thing okay
um
trying to figure out like where's the
best place i'm gonna do healing let's
worry about do we have food and do we
have a roof okay and then we're gonna
start figuring out okay what is the
paperwork process do we have an attorney
someone's gonna walk alongside us in
this divorce and make sure the assets
are all separated and everything and
people say things like i'm gonna make
sure i pay off all the debt when we
leave and all this stuff
man then lawyers get involved and
everybody gets messy and so i would wait
until the smoke clears on the actual
divorce and dave is says this best
once somebody says i want a divorce and
they move out
the relationship is gone from a romantic
it transitions from a romantic
relationship to a business transaction
that's where you get an attorney because
now this is a business interaction
between you and this man um that you
were married to
see the difference there
yeah and now it's about protecting you
and that little girl and making sure
you're able to separate with dignity and
then
then we're gonna start thinking about
healing where's the best place should i
sell this condo and all that kind of
stuff you see what i'm saying
um key here is make sure you surround
yourself with other people
yeah you cannot i've had a really great
support system good good good good so
will you ask for help and lean into it
yeah okay maybe set up meal trains i'm
gonna need somebody to take care of this
and this and this for a season anybody
have a good attorney will somebody go
with me to talk to the lawyer because
i'm only going to hear part of it
because i'm going to be in shock see
what i'm saying like get somebody to go
with you on these things
and that will be in your corner as
you're figuring out what comes next
okay do you have income right now amy
are you working outside the home
before yeah the baby
uh yes i do okay do you see yourself
going back to work
yeah definitely um
i make 118 a year and i've got a i've
got two kids now so
i've got to work
what does child care look like
um we have a great we have a great day
care um and we had been planning to to
send them both there once i go back so
um
yeah i'm just in the middle of my leave
now so just sitting around absorbing all
this how old is how old is your youngest
i mean you're uh your oldest
he's three years old oh my gosh geez
louise
um
a great gift you can give him
is to
not act stoic and rock solid through
this process
let him see mom be sad
and don't use him as a
as a prop to hold you up because he
can't carry your the weight of your pain
in the way of your hurt
but
his body is going to react to dead
moving out and his body's going to react
to mom's anxiousness and the transition
and what are we doing and why his
grandmother over here all the time all
that kind of stuff
and if he sees mom be sad too and says
you know
bubba i'm sad also
can i give you a hug
and he gives you a hug
and he sees you cry and then he sees you
get up and go help
you know get food on the table get some
things going on um
uh
that's gonna be a gift for him because
he's not gonna feel crazy he's gonna
feel like he's just like mommy and
mommy's sad too amy i wanna give you one
more gift hang on the line austin will
pick up i'm gonna get you connected with
a financial coach on us in the boise
area who can walk with you through this
process and please please call us back
if you need anything else i'm gonna give
you a copy on your past change your
future as well you can get that book and
start working through that as uh
figure out what comes next we're so so
sorry we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show eight eight two
five five two two five blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
like george did with his jacket today
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from alex in chattanooga
my father-in-law wants to take the whole
family seven adults four kids to
scotland in 2024 his scheme is to pay
for the air tickets with american
express credit card points he has
ordered cards for his three daughters
and wants them to pay for everything in
their life with them and pay him back on
a weekly or monthly basis
not sure of that detail yet he has
already decided this and the cards are
in the mail apparently he needs about 1
million points to get all the tickets
for free i know this is a horrific idea
i don't know how to tell him no on this
can we just before we get into this it's
kind of a great idea like brilliant i
see this guy he's was like in a in an
ihop and he was like wait a minute
and then he's like uh had a napkin and
started doing the math it was like
i could take my whole family oh it needs
a million points a million points this
is like when i was at chuck e cheese and
i was like okay i need
40 000 tickets to get the boombox and so
i'd spend like 20 bucks 30 bucks and i'd
end up with like 400 tickets and they
gave you like a little sticky hand yep
and like a pack of gum and so with 18
thousand dollars i could get that boom
box up there with 40
okay so uh he's asking i don't know how
to tell him no it's a father-in-law it's
a it's messy it's a little bit of a
different relationship all right so
um anytime somebody's asking me george
how do i tell somebody no on this
um
we always practice i said repeat after
me
no thank you
and then they'll look at me like i'm
kind of an idiot and then they'll say no
thank you i'll be like that look at that
you did that right you did it so here's
what we have here we have a
father-in-law who loves his family
and he wants to do a really cool thing i
would even go as far to read into this
story is that there's something in their
family lineage in scotland right maybe
it's we're going to go back and see
where great great great great
grandparents lived or something
the whole idea here is pretty cool
and the father-in-law um wants to honor
everybody we're going to do this and
father-in-law looks in the bank account
and says i can't pay for 11 people to go
for a week to scotland fair enough very
few father-in-laws could do that
but he figured out a plan um it's just
that the plan as as alex writes is a
horrific idea right
um
george walk through why is this a
terrible idea i've got my own opinion on
it but go ahead well number one he's
apparently forcing his daughters to
use credit cards to fund their life in
order to get these points and so i look
at it logically i look at the goal right
the goal is scotland 2024 for 11 people
and i go okay how much is that going to
cost so then i go okay we have two years
to save up let's say it's three thousand
dollars a person
then i go okay daughter number one could
you save up three thousand dollars in
the next two years what would that take
to do that with cash
and i guarantee you it's a lot easier
than the scheme of hoping you have
enough points and by two years from now
let's hope american express hasn't
changed their program and what those
points are actually valued at and what
the blackout dates are and which
airlines and places you can fly to and
worse it's a nightmare worse built into
this is hey honey you owe me 49
hey honey you owe me 706 dollars and
what happens when they can't pay because
they overspent to trying to help dad get
as many points as possible or they have
they have a 700 costco bill and they
swipe it and then all of a sudden the
transmission falls out and they got to
fix that and then now dad's like wait a
minute guys i got i need my
but john there was six percent
points
if you shop online at this specific
retailer so that's why i spent a
thousand dollars gotcha in order to get
the six percent instead of the four
points i needed 111 pairs of banana
republic socks so that i could get this
is the game we're playing now the
numbers here are outrageous a million
points of anything regardless of what we
don't know what these points are worth
so great so look at bitcoin all right
here's my problem with it okay and you
know i've talked about this just hanging
out
um let's say this works perfectly
let's say
the family they're all in they come up
with a foolproof system
we are going to every week we're going
to write data check for the money that
we spent we're going to spend anyway
we're going to spend this money anyway
we had to buy groceries anyway we had to
pay for rent anyway we had to do all
these things anyway we just threw on
this
american express card and then we wrote
dad a check instead of writing it to um
our rent or to our light bill or
whatever everything works out perfectly
and the family takes a 100
free trip to scotland in 2024 it all
works here's what got me out of this
system
um because i'm somebody who used points
and we paid it off every month it never
affected my family other than i was
quote unquote winning and it was a light
bulb moment for me when i realized
oh this credit card company is not my
friend they're not just giving me free
flights in hotels because they like me
and they're like you've been so good to
us bro we're going to be good that's not
how they work
then i realized that there's a single
mom with three kids trying to figure out
she can put gas in the car because it's
tripled in price
and she can't figure it out she's got to
swipe this card and it's got a 500 limit
and she's having to balance that card
with another one with a 250 limit and
she's paying for my flight
and i'm not gonna be a part of a system
that preys on people who can't make
their payments or who found themselves
suddenly a single mom like the last
caller or who's living in a city and all
sudden rents tripled i'm not going to go
to scotland for free on the backs of
those men and women who are trying to
scratch and call their way through life
i'm opting out of a corrupt system that
preys on people who have less than or
who are struggling i'm not gonna play
i couldn't enjoy a trip to scotland that
i got for free knowing that it was paid
for by people who can't like who are
struggling yeah right um or who have not
don't have enough control in their life
or who use um uh who use
shopping as some form of medication or
some sort of anxiety relief from trauma
i'm not gonna play that game i'm opting
out i'd rather pay for my trip to
scotland i'd rather tell my family i
want to do this cool thing like you
mentioned earlier in two years can we
all save up can we all be a part of this
i'd rather that than this pretend thing
like i'm taking this all for free you
all just do chores for me for the next
two years
yeah you do chores for me for the next
two years and then we're all going for
free i'm just not playing that game so
it's not so it's more of a it's a hard
thing if you truly believe it's free
then their marketing is working very
very well that's right or that they're
friends with you that's amazing because
what's going to take truthfully they're
gonna have to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on those cards over
the next two years in order to get their
million points and even if you were
gonna do it anyway
don't play in a system that preys on
other people just don't man not worth it
yeah so just save up so give yourself
some passion here's the here's the the
truth before we pass this on
your father-in-law comes to you and says
hey um this is what we're doing this is
how we're doing it
the conversation um is probably
again uh me and a friend of mine argue
on this but
i think your wife is the one or your hus
i don't know if alex is a man or woman
but whoever is this the the direct child
of this father-in-law sits down and says
hey
i don't play with credit cards i don't
participate in this a game you let me
know how much the tickets cost and i'll
let you know if we can afford our
family's ability to go and we will put
in the cash on this trip but i don't
participate in this and it might be are
you come on it's all figured out it's
all cool that's great man i just don't i
don't play in that game and if your
father-in-law doesn't respect your
family's boundaries in that way this
trip to scotland's gonna be a pretty
awful adventure so you're you've opted
out thank goodness you avoided a pretty
disastrous trip together right yeah i
only see the one of two ways either
father-in-law goes hey i want to gift
this to you guys with no strings
attached or hey i'd love to go on this
trip let me know if you guys can make it
and if we can afford it there you go but
there's a weird in-between of you got to
play by my rules and sign up for this
credit card and pay me back every month
for everything you that creates a very
different dynamic in the relationship
yeah it
it just it just sounds like i've come up
with a great idea you just do uh chores
for me for a long time it reminds me the
call dave took where he a guy said hey i
want to buy a pay phone for the house
and everyone puts quarters in it and
then i get all the money and i would get
free phones and dave's like don't you
have to pay for like you know the phone
line like the air that the phone
and the guy was like i didn't think
about that dang it i thought i scammed
the system
and
oh boy
good job yeah um speaking of scamming
the system um that's the first hour in
the books today ladies and gentlemen we
did it that we did it um even though you
got denim on denim here george and we're
still going anyway we're going strong
hey we'll be back in the next hour uh
join us triple eight eight two five five
two two five we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
have a conversation
about your life your money your
relationships your work i am john dolone
joined here by george campbell and we
are taking your calls just about
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five two two five the call is
free give us a buzz let's go out to uh
huntington west virginia and talk to
kane what's up kane
how's it going guys i'm so happy to be
talking to you guys we are you are
you're the first kane either us i've
ever talked to on the show it's good to
talk to you man
that's good and i don't have a horse
uh thank you kane
kane knows how i feel about horse phones
you know what i mean yeah yeah
that's a whole other thing all right so
what's up man
i got a two-part question i've got
i'm having a little bit of trouble
getting my wife
on board
and then just i'm letting everything
go as my income's just keeping us afloat
on everything that we do i've got some
rental properties and stuff
but our mortgage is pretty heavy and i'm
just trying to get a base on what
i know i've heard you tell people before
like you can if you can pay it off
just you know a lot of times just tell
them to sell the rentals
but i've never heard anybody say that
they had rentals that was paid off you
know
versus not being paid off normally
they've got mortgages and stuff on them
so i was just trying to get a basis on
what let's start at the very beginning
here you said you're having a hard time
getting your wife on board with what
um just the ramsey plan in general i
mean she
she knows that i'm you know
real apt to just
you know i try to push it on a lot of
people between my sister and
her and just family members because i
know what such a good thing it does for
people and i
i try to get it
out to the world you know
so
uh it's not a big secret that i'm a
super nerd okay that's nobody's this
that's not for debate um
i hide some of the depths of my nerdum
and i'll let you in on some on one of my
nerd secrets is that cool
back in the day i used to have a
spreadsheet that i kept
and i went and bought my own glucose
monitor and
my glucose strips and i would keep my i
would keep my blood sugar levels and i'd
keep my ketone levels and now every
month i would try a new fad diet and i
wanted to track and see what was
happening in my body and if it worked
good and what my weight was and how my
energy levels were and all this stuff
it got to the point that my wife every
month would say because she's just
awesome she'd say what are we this week
are we raw vegan are we keto what are we
doing
and every week i'd read a new book and
be like this is the thing
and i became
like
worst like yes i was insufferable
i can keep going evangelizing to
everyone kane you got to be on this diet
it's the best it's so good
and one thing i could confirm with a
hundred percent accuracy not a single
person was ever
ever converted
to my diet of the day
um by me evangelizing to them in that
way
the only time i've been able to over the
years
um
quote-unquote convince people
to change their life is just to show up
and keep doing my thing
and they say hey you seem to be happier
than me your marriage look looks
different than my marriage you seem your
kids want to be around you more than my
kids want to be honest
how do you do it in that so you see what
i'm saying kane
you're coming at your wife with a scheme
with a plan and the fact that you've got
a bunch of paid for rental houses but
your house still
you've always got a thing going don't
you
oh
absolutely so you're a guy with a thing
so you come with your wife and you say
hey i got a new scheme and she goes all
right that's there we go
that's different than this
hey honey we
owe money and it scares me
and i don't say that word very much
because i'm a tough guy from huntington
but owing other people money scares me
every month not knowing how much money
we have in in the bank in this real
heavy mortgage and i'm working as hard
as i'm working and i don't know where we
are
and i don't know what you're spending i
don't know what i'm spending i don't
know how much groceries cost i feel
disassociated from my own family
and i'd love to
picture you and me in a paid for
vacation home someday
and our kids going to college because
we've saved for it would you be willing
to go on that journey with me it's a
journey of peace and safety
you see how that one's a different one's
a scheme and one is i love you so much
that you see what i'm saying
yeah absolutely and one of them involves
her yeah that's the difference so kane
have you asked her like hey what are
your goals
what do you want to do
yeah i mean we're pretty goal-oriented
but yeah i focus you know
she's a stay-at-home mom and watches the
boys so i i you know i want to treat her
the best i can and
and stuff like that but so i can i was
in the marketing world for many years
and in the marketing world you always
look at customers pain points or their
felt need and that's how you best reach
them with your product or service so i
want you to take that approach with your
wife and go hey what are her pain points
what is she struggling with right now
and what are the points that touch money
and how can i connect the baby steps to
those pain points and then all of a
sudden she goes oh my gosh yes i can be
a stay-at-home mom and not have to worry
about if you're going to be able to make
ends meet because we don't have any debt
anymore we have a paid for house because
we sold the rental it changes the lens
in which he looks at this whole plan and
here's a magic way this is both to you
kane and all the men listening
a magic way to at to find out what your
spouse's pain points are
is to ask them don't go home and
announce her pain points to hurricane
right
right
you're like oh man and if you're going
to do the baby steps we're not going to
be ish we got to be all in on this
because it's going to show her that
you're serious this time and this isn't
another scheme and that you're not going
to be halfway in and then choose a
different plan three months later
i think when she sees that level of
intensity and sacrifice and what and the
fact that you're doing this for the
family and not just because kane had
another hair brained idea it's going to
change the way she looks at this
this conversation starts with you
you
not telling her hey you need a
babysitter for the kids i won't take you
out not that you find a babysitter cane
and you let your wife know um
i want to take you out and we're gonna
do something special and i want you to
take her out to somewhere special and i
want you to have a nice journal that
you've bought for her
um
and hand her a pen
and you have one yourself
and i want you to tell her one thing we
haven't been doing since the kids came
along since uh we had the rental house
here and this rental house there and we
bought this big house then
we've not sat down and dreamed together
and we haven't sat down and planned
together and i don't know what your
needs are in this new season
and i want to reimagine what our
marriage looks like and start the
conversation with this kane
i'm i'm a schemer
as the great vince neil says you know
i'm a dreamer you're going to start out
with you know i'm a schemer and this
isn't one of my schemes this is me
wanting to
get to know my wife again and get to
know our home again and i want us to
plan for the future and by the way as a
part of this plan a really big deal for
me
is that uh we don't know anybody
anything and i know that if i don't land
this particular job
that we're still going to be okay and
that you can like george was mentioned
you can do what you want to at the house
if you want to hire somebody to come
home for a couple of days to come to the
house for a couple of days so you can go
out and you think we're good yeah okay
and on top of that i'm gonna gift you
guys financial peace university watch
those lessons with her you can also
start your every dollar budget with that
hang on the line austin will pick up
that's our gift to you
we'll be right back
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
let me ask you a question when you think
of a millionaire what kind of job do you
picture them having is this some kind of
high-powered executive position like a
vp or a ceo is it dr john deloney well
here's the thing only 15 percent of
millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is that the top five
careers for millionaires in america are
as follows engineer accountant teacher
manager and attorney that's just one of
the surprising things our team found out
when we conducted the largest study of
millionaires ever done we talked to tens
of thousands of millionaires to find out
who they are and how they achieve that
goal our study also made it abundantly
clear that to become a millionaire
you've got to invest wisely and a big
part of that is getting good investing
advice you got to work with an investing
pro who can walk with you and teach you
about the options that are right for you
our team recommends trustworthy vetted
investing pros from all over the country
we call them smart vester pros if you
want to get in touch with one in your
area go to ramseysolutions.com smart
vester and start building wealth today
all right let's go to sabrina in salt
lake city that's fine there she is
what's up sabrina
hi um i just graduated from college and
i've been sitting at parent's house for
the past month the thing is that just
due to some family differences i'm gonna
be moving out um tomorrow to my
boyfriend's parents house they've given
me a really big blessing um until i find
my own place how exactly do i prepare to
leave
um there and i guess how long should i
be staying there because they they
obviously told me you can live forever
but that's not the case you know sure
what happened at your home
just some family differences like they
didn't like um there was like no drugs
or alcohol or anything they just didn't
like the way that um i was doing things
in life and yeah okay
um
so
i think in number one
um i'm
proud of you for being an adult and
saying it's time for me to go and you're
not on the air throwing grenades and
they're the worst whatever like you're
actually sounding pretty grown up like
we have some differences and i'm moving
on and that's called the boundary and so
good for you um as for your boyfriend's
parents house good on them for seeing
somebody in need and saying hey you're
welcome to be here um
the i think you are very very wise
to
not take the you can just stay here
forever like ah no i can't
and so here's what i think would be uh
help make this interaction um successful
i would come up with a date three months
four months
and
say uh sit down with them and say what
are
uh
i'm moving into your home what are the
rules here you'll be home at a certain
time do you want me um
what can i do to help around here and
they're gonna say nothing nothing and i
think it's important for you to say no
i'm gonna do something i'm gonna
participate in the life of this home
um
are you gonna pay rent pay a hundred
bucks pay 200 bucks pay something small
the year before i got married when i was
saving up money i moved in with a
friend's parents and
um i paid a small amount of rent but it
was important for everybody that i had
some skin in that game
and um we had a very clear exit date
this is when this is gonna this is when
this time so i'm going to be out
and it puts you on the hot seat to save
some money work some side hustles to do
whatever you got to do to go get your
own apartment and also it left
everything clear right so i would go in
and just have a direct conversation
about their values with what you can do
to help around the house and let's go
ahead and put an end date on paper and
maybe the four months come and go pretty
quick
and then this guy
um you're a fiancee suddenly and so i'm
gonna i'm gonna stay another five months
or something until but
let's at least get um a preliminary date
on the books that we all shake hands and
agree does that sound good
yeah so sabrina you said you graduated
are you working right now
um no my job starts in october that's
kind of the big thing here because like
i just don't i mean like i'm going to
get a job at target starting monday um
but
yeah so you'll have some income planning
on children what will you be making at
target
um 17 an hour okay i want you to put as
much of that away in savings as possible
to take advantage of this uh amazing
blessing where you're not paying market
rate rent for a while
that's gonna set you up really nicely
when you enter this full-time job is it
already set up you've accepted an offer
yeah yeah awesome what kind of job is it
um software engineering oh fantastic do
you know the starting pay
yeah
it's 105. that's kind of the thing like
i'm set like once i'm like once i get my
first paycheck or like like the first
couple of paychecks in but so what if we
said hey i'm gonna live here until i
start this full-time job and i'm gonna
immediately move out and rent somewhere
either on my own or if i can't afford it
i'm gonna find a roommate
yeah that sounds perfect i love what i
was thinking sabrina let me um
let me i'm gonna push on one thing you
said okay
you said um i got this great job
starting in october but i was planning
on chilling between now and october a
recipe for relational mess a recipe for
mental health distress
is this idea that i'm just going to do
nothing i'm just going to quote unquote
chill
okay
the second thing is you made a very
grown-up decision to leave your parents
house sounds like it was the right
decision for you
but
sometimes we have plans i'm gonna go on
vacation and then suddenly i lose our
job or i'm going to do this thing then
the world shifts underneath us and you
had this plan where between august and
october i'm just gonna i'm gonna kind of
lay low because i got this awesome job
i'm gonna work at target a few hours a
week to be cool
you made a grown-up decision to step out
and that means you probably cashed in
the idea that i was just going to be
chilling
so my recommendation to you is yes you
keep that job at target but you also get
another job of starbucks in the evenings
or you also drive in the evenings too
for the next august september i want you
to work pretty tough get after yourself
a little bit save some money so that
october when you start this new job you
can
move into your new place and be ready to
rock and roll the other thing george i
see this happen a lot is
people sign an agreement for several
months in advance and they think
everything's going to be great if
there's cutbacks to be made in some of
these companies they start with people
who haven't started working here yet
right that's the one that happened to me
out of college okay i spent all summer
banking on this job i thought i was a
shoe-in they were like oh yeah it's
going to be great i interviewed and then
the very end of the summer they sent me
an email that was like unfortunately we
have found that you were not a fit for
this position and i was just
flabbergasted right because i had stayed
in this place chilling all summer going
i got this first full-time job it's
gonna be great and then i was scrambling
that's right so you got to kind of plan
for the plan to not go to plan always
plan for the plan to not go to without
putting yourself in paranoia yes yes yes
and negativity
it's a delicate balance john you have
found the balance yeah i i don't know if
i have
i don't know all right let's go to
rebecca in wisconsin what's up rebecca
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call you bet hey we're up against the
clock so get right to the question
okay so i just got engaged three weeks
ago i'm on baby step two and my fiance
just started reading dave ramsey as well
i am wondering i have five thousand
dollars left of baby step two do i put a
pause on baby step two and save up for
the wedding or do i do both
simultaneously
well are the options we go into debt for
the wedding in order to pay off the
other debt
no okay so could we continue paying off
the debt and still cash flow a wedding
and make it five thousand dollars
cheaper is that an option
i think so
i think that's a cool plan but worst
case yeah i don't want you going to debt
for the weddings if that means paying
minimum payments on our debt for a few
more months i'm okay with that because i
don't want you to you know continue
bleeding here going further into debt
but i love the plan of saying hey how
can we continue this intensity so that
we can start our marriage off completely
debt-free and cash flow a wedding and
the flowers that we would have paid
three thousand dollars for they would
have died in four hours anyways we won't
miss them right
very straight down his budget so yes i
love it um do you have a budget for the
wedding
yes 15 000.
cool and how much how close are you to
paying that
um we
cash cash flowing i'm a thousand short
my fiance has his okay so you're saying
we're a thousand short so it's not
really going to affect your debt payoff
plan then
not exactly that's why i didn't know if
i should just put a hold for two months
and just keep saving it up that way my
whole wedding is paid for and then i how
about this
let's get intense about getting this
cash flow wedding once that money's
sitting there let's go after the debt
and see if we can pay it off by the
wedding as a personal challenge and
let's have one more personal challenge
let's have a little bit of fun i want
you and your fiance to go out on a date
and see if you can get this fifteen
thousand dollar wedding to twelve
thousand five hundred bucks see if you
can cut it start negotiating say i'll
pay this vendor in cash we're gonna cut
this person a check they're giving us
400 bucks back here we're gonna have
aunt sally make the cake we're gonna do
something we're gonna get another 12.5
we're gonna take that money and get that
deadpool and sally makes a great cake
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john dolone joined by my good friend
george campbell let's go out to regina
in san antonio texas what's up regina
hey how you guys doing today good how
are you
great huge fan of the show thank you so
much for taking my call you bet we're a
huge fan of yours what's up
so i'm currently working for a retail
company i've been working here for about
four going on five years they've been
really good to me they have 180 hours of
pto they have insurance benefits they
have free therapy sessions for their
employees
and
i currently got an offer for another job
now this retail job is not necessarily
in my field i've been doing customer
service the entire time
and this new job is a marketing
coordinator with a non-profit which is
awesome however
they have only 80 hours of pto
but they do have like other good
benefits they do six percent match and
the 403 b i think it is
and
they also have
paid
uh what do you call it holidays from
christmas to new year's eve but it's a 5
000 decrease in my income so i'm a
little torn just because i've been so
loyal to you know this company that i'm
with right now and i'm currently working
in corporate since november
so i was hoping to grow with the company
but it's a little slower than i've
expected but this nonprofit's giving me
an opportunity to be in my field of
marketing and i recently just got my mba
so i've been kind of struggling on
trying to find a job in the field
is this new position going to get you
closer to what you see yourself doing
three to five years from now
yes because of the experience that i'd
be gaining
i'm just i've set myself up i guess to
live
the current salary that i live
but so here's what i'll tell you in my
personal life on multiple occasions i've
taken a pay cut
to go from a job
um that i was either through with or was
um doing great with to a another job
that i was gonna do even better or that
had a higher upside to it or i was gonna
learn some new skills
multiple times a hundred percent every
time i've done that it's paid itself off
in the long run both in my life
because my life was better
and financially just just the math
um
it sounds like you are
willing to trade being miserable
um
and not being frustrated at work for a
lifestyle that you've set up that's a
couple hundred dollars a month more than
um like
you see what i'm saying seems like a
strange trade to me talk to me about
that
i guess just because like with the
current company i have they give us the
free therapy sessions and i utilize
those you know just to stay on top of my
mental health
and i mean you're at a job that you
don't want to be yet and so then you
they cover the therapy
okay take the benefits off the table for
a second which job do you want what
lights you up when you think about doing
that for eight hours a day
i mean honestly it'd be really fun to be
in like working with a non-profit as a
marketing coordinator that sounds like
the dream and the next step however
i don't know i mean i just i'm so used
to being with this retailer company and
like now that i've had the corporate
opportunity i'm that's it making a
decision because you're used to it is a
terrible filter for making a decision
yes you are trying to make this about
vacation it's not you're just scared and
that's okay
i was in dean of students at a billion
dollar college and i'm a youtuber dude i
get it it was a scary job right yeah you
know this whole thing and then you move
over here it's it's um it's a tough move
and
it sounds like it's the right move
regina if you if you hate this marketing
coordinator position could you leave two
years from now and go be a senior
marketer somewhere else
and make 10 15 20 grand more
maybe i'm just scared because i've
applied to like 30 places and this
non-profit's the only one who's giving
me a chance well do you have marketing
experience right
now i have about a year or two under my
belt but it's nothing corporate level or
you know it was for a university i mean
it's pretty big
but i say if you're excited about it you
go for it and if you can live on 400
less than you are now because you're
following this plan you're gonna have
some bigger upside on the back end i
started here as a marketing coordinator
you know nine years ago and there's
growth if you're crushing it they're
gonna go hey we wanna put you in this
position in this position and if there's
not growth you can leave that's right it
may not be the last job you ever have
and that's okay i promise you it won't
be the last job you ever have
okay i have one more rebuttal and then
you guys can find more i love your
rebuttal bring it back
sorry sorry so i've always had two jobs
like i just finished my mba i went to
school full time i had a full-time job
and i had a part-time job so i'm super
used to being super busy now i only have
this full-time job so i don't feel
secure not having i guess a second job
that well do you have debt i really like
i'm sorry do you have any debt
i do i have my grad school and my credit
cards which i'm also i'm following the
baby steps so i mean i'm doing that you
know it's just i guess the whole career
gina regina is not having a job
yes
just just a fellow texan to another
texan you and i just having chips and
queso just hanging out okay
yeah what are you running from
security
yeah
somewhere along the way somebody told
you that you're not enough
you're never gonna have enough
that all the stuff comes crashing down
on you
and your um
your addiction is busy
yeah probably addiction
it's a little bit your anxiety's about
chaos it's a little bit busy and what
you're doing is you're using busy you're
using achievement you're using go go go
go go go
as a
as xanax
as a way to bandaid over
just being present and still for a
minute because when you're present and
still you got to look in the mirror
and for some reason you don't like
regina that much or you think you'll
like her more if she gets this degree
from this place at this cost and then
gets this job and makes this much money
and what i'll promise you is
the great
the great tragedy of mba programs is
they don't tell you this one fundamental
truth no matter what job you get no
matter what salary you can negotiate for
you go with you everywhere
yeah and the world is littered with
people who were vice presidents and had
fancy cars in 5 000 square foot houses
and they imploded everything
and so a great move for you
professionally and personally
is to take a job that you love that is
going to be a job that's going to teach
you things at a much slower pace and you
can use this time to heal and get well
and figure out what comes next
yeah see what i'm saying
and i want you to start getting my
therapist
i want you to start getting curious
about your body trying to protect you
every time it starts to get that angsty
feeling
that saturday morning at 10 a.m feeling
you know what i'm talking about that i
should be doing i should be doing i
should be doing yeah ask yourself
quietly with a smile on your face what's
my body trying to protect me from
what about me what about this moment
isn't safe
and you need to answer those questions
because when you make peace with those
questions you can work anywhere for any
amount of money and then when you can
work anywhere for any amount of money
people really want to hire you they come
after you then
yeah that makes sense does that make
sense regina heard you say multiple
times well i'm used to having the second
job i'm used to i'm used to that doesn't
mean it's good it doesn't mean it's
normal
and so let's find a new number i just
had one job i felt so stressed out like
i felt so i feel like i was getting
dirty
yeah you didn't feel stressed out you
felt worthless
you felt lazy
yeah and that's a lie i want to get to
the point where regina can just sit with
regina and not feel like i'm not doing
enough from not being enough
my friends that work with professional
athletes tell me
getting a professional athlete into the
gym isn't the hard part teaching them
the benefits and the power and the
critical importance of rest
and
so i want you to look at rest as a skill
i want you to look at peace as a skill
something you got to practice because
you don't know how to do it
yep you need to learn that right so hey
all right we're going to practice it
we're not going to beat ourselves up
about it we're not we're not a
leadership failure we have character
issues no we it's a skill
my guess is you and i could talk for a
long time and you've been running hot
since you were a little kid and those
same
those same things that kept you safe as
a kid kept you alive as a kid um are the
things are going to burn you out as an
adult so all that means is you gotta
learn some new skills
and we say this i say it all time and
probably too much but i'm gonna keep
saying it
you're worth being well
and you're worth peace
and you're worth falling asleep at night
without medication you're worth getting
up in the morning and drinking coffee
because you want to not because you have
to and you're worth only working one job
sometimes
you're worth
peace
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to john in bakersfield california
what's up john
hi how's it going excellent brother
what's up
uh so just a little background i've been
with my girlfriend here for a while
we're both in our 30s
no debts no kids
we both make good money i make about 90
a year she makes about 1 30.
so we each own our own house right now
we'll probably get engaged here very
soon and we've talked about when we do
get married we're going to move into her
house i like her house a little better
she's been there longer than i have well
done kind of done everything to set it
up
she thinks when i move in
she'd like to keep my house as a rental
property um i could probably net about
800 to a thousand dollars a month on it
although with what i already have into
the house and how the market is and i've
lived in it for over two years so as far
as i understand i wouldn't pay any
capital gains tax
i could probably get about 200 grand
just straight out of it so just kind of
wondering your opinion on which will be
the smarter route what's the house worth
my house i bought for 320 just
over a little over two years ago i have
about 80 into it for my down payment and
the principal i've paid down and now
it's selling uh you know just with other
sales around it and i've looked it up on
zillow for about four
forty four fifty
okay and she's got a mortgage on her
place
yeah she's lived in her place for 10
years she got it for a great deal back
in the day hers is worth more than
double what it is now but uh my thinking
is if i get that 200 grand out i've
driven my car for the last eight years
i'm gonna need a new one i could buy
that in cash i could pay off the car she
just got in cash and even pay off her
you know our mortgage in her house and
we'd be living free
yeah i like john's plan more because
number one you won't have two mortgages
to keep up with and you're not starting
off your marriage as a landlord trying
to get your 800 bucks a month while
you're probably spending 800 bucks a
month to keep this thing afloat
yes yeah with all the other things i
would build on and plus i i haven't had
a car payment for the last eight years i
don't want one my car's on his last leg
like i'd love to just buy my car in cash
pay off the extra 15 that hers is in
cash and even if not paying off her
mortgage i figure
whenever the market starts to slow down
again or something i could still have
another 100 and something in the bank to
go out and get another one or two
properties in the future
okay hold on real quick
you said you don't want to go into debt
that's like getting married and being
like i don't want to cheat on you just
don't never do it okay just don't ever
go into debt right um i'm with george
man sell the sell your rental property
pay your wife's house off and she might
be upset going well we could be making 9
000 a year off this thing yeah it could
also be adding a whole lot of stress and
it could cost you 10 grand a year and so
i think you having a real conversation
go on a date and say hey i think this is
going to set us up so well in the future
we can pay down the mortgage we won't
have any debt it's going to give us so
much more options and i want to pay off
our mortgage and then one day we're
going to do a rental that's hours
together and we're going to do it with
cash and quick math what is your uh what
do you pay in um what's your mortgage
every month
uh just under 16.
so if you don't have that mortgage
anymore
is that like uh
having some money
in the house you see what i'm saying oh
yeah no i mean i could i could obvio
like for the way the rentals are going
around here i could get somebody in it
for around probably 25 or 26 they play
if they pay
them said 800 to a thousand yeah i was
saying the opposite there but all that
to say is your yes sell your house sell
it be debt free start a marriage no i
meant 800 to a thousand as in i could
get that out of it every single month
like profit day 16 yeah profit every
month okay yeah i don't think the extra
10 grand is going to change your life i
think what will change your life is
selling it being completely debt free
being able to throw some at her mortgage
and you guys have a head start on this
amazing new marriage yeah i'm 100 i'm
just more excited about that just on an
emotional level yes on top of that as
two guys who are married and who
don't own any credit card companies it's
a pretty awesome way to deal with a
marriage disagreement not also being
pressured by bank of america let's go to
uh mike in scranton what's up mike oh
chef
hey guys how you doing nice to talk to
you you too what's up man
hey uh i got a question almost
when that last call i just mentioned
about a vehicle uh
i'm just curious
whether i should or could be able to buy
a another used vehicle i'm driving a
hooptie quote that dave says for the
last you know seven years it's a minivan
it's almost 20 years old over 200 000
miles on it nickel and dime in me and
you know my two kids are teenagers now
so it's not cool anymore yeah
but it still runs you know but i take it
to the you know garage like it seems
like every other month to get something
fixed and repaired and i just you know
just got out of the garage because my
window was broken hold on
you're you're giving me a very emotional
plea to a math problem
okay so that's it okay can you afford
the car i'm glad you're on the phone
john because
i have trouble trying to separate my
money well you hate money but i'm afraid
to give it up you hate the car good deal
can you afford it
what's that like what i'm looking for
yeah can you go buy another car how much
money do you have right now
in savings well i was looking to spend
maybe at least 15 000 you know to buy
another vehicle but you know in my area
here trying to find something that's a
little
for that price or less with low mileage
like at least 100 to 130 000 miles you
know you're looking yours has two
hundred thousand a hundred thousand is
low mileage to you yeah man well i know
that's why i'm trying i'm trying to find
something with the right you can find
something for fifteen thousand dollars
that doesn't have two hundred thousand
miles but hey come on do you have the
money that's the question do you have
15k
yeah i have the money yes i have the
money but uh hold on do you have a lot
more money
i i have see i have money saved up and
that's another issue
but
i also have a disabled son so you know
the reason we have a van with two red
kids and then my son is in a wheelchair
so i need i can't just go buy like a
like a a small car i need to have
something that could put you know like a
small uh suv type of vehicle okay let me
give you an suv but let me press you a
little bit
um
you've had to deal with some hard stuff
haven't you
yes and that my wife also passed away
two from cancer about six years ago so
i'm okay single dad too so
so you've you when i say you've done
hard stuff you have done hard stuff
right
and
you also
know what better than most of us that
things can get really
sideways real fast right
true is your response because mine is
very similar
is your response to things to get
sideways very fast
um being really tight with your money
is that a coping strategy here's what
i'm asking you can you go buy a 50 000
van that's relatively nice
relatively new that would take care of
your son's needs and that is good i
wouldn't do that not at all you would
no you wouldn't i wouldn't i mean i have
the cash in the savings but i wouldn't
want to do that because it's just too
much money you know just based off of
dave's theory so you know
how much do you make a year
like around 65 70. okay all right that's
fair
um so
i i would challenge you
to like man i just hear myself and you
um i don't know i don't have a child
with special needs but i also have x
number of dollars in the bank and i
still think i bet i could get a car for
5 000 bucks
and at some point
it takes somebody walking alongside me
asking me hey what are you trying to
prove
is it a scarcity thing is it a fear
thing because you got the money to get
something nicer
um that is going to be a more of a
blessing for you and your family then
buying a fifteen thousand dollar car and
just holding your breath until you gotta
sell it
right and it just doesn't sound like
you're in fifteen thousand dollar car
territory right now
is that fair
that's fair yeah
okay and you're talking to a guy that
drives an 06
with almost 200 000 miles on it like so
i'm not i'm not a new car i got an old
two and a half so there you go so this
is old car guy to older car guy i'm
telling you if you've got the money
and um you're not going to be doing
something irresponsible which i don't
hear that at all
i want to challenge you to
give yourself a little grace here okay
well that's another yeah well i have the
money but i have no that's another phone
call to dave or you guys ask about what
should i do with that money because
right now i just i sold some property to
get some of that money and i'm
i've it's just in my savings account so
i'm like
i i guess i'll wait till the tax season
because i'm not sure if i'm going to get
hit with a capital gains on that or not
i actually sold it for a little less
than what i paid for it so i'm not
too sure but you know i don't know how
to i'd rather put that money somewhere
into investments like you know you guys
recommend but
right now i have it so well let's start
with the short term goal which is get a
better car and if you can get a 20 grand
car that'll get you at 2015 instead of a
2012. but dude you work hard you've been
busting it it's time you've been through
a lot and
call one of our tax pros go to um
ramseysolutions.com and check out one of
our smart investor pros and our tax
professionals and they will get you
lined up with the information because
what you need right now brother is some
information so you can have some
peace
this is the ramsay show we'll be back
soon
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your money and your life and your
relationships really just about
everything your work all
i'm john dalone joined here by my good
friend george campbell and we're taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to robert in georgia what's up robert
hey good afternoon
good afternoon to you what's up
oh well first i'd like to say thanks for
your
devotion to helping people with money
and stuff i've been a long time listener
and i got a question here to maybe get
some guidance you got it what's up man
all right so recently i've been divorced
still kind of going through the legal
process due to an appeal
however
uh recently sold the marital home and i
now have half the profits
i'm debt debt-free
and i'm renting right now and i'm
wondering
should i
think about taking that money from the
sale of the house and
buying another property or should i rent
for a while and i totally get that house
prices are probably not going to be
going down anytime soon so i don't know
tell me about this tell me about the
legal appeal
um yeah so basically the
the everything was finalized
and
i got
uh
custody primary custody and everything
and
basically my ex came in and appealed
everything
and if you know anything about legal
stuff it takes forever yep so
so we're
waiting on hearing back the results from
the appeals court now how long has this
divorce process been going on
uh it started
2020
and um
the appeal was filed so you know it took
about a year to go through the whole
process
for the
local court
and then appeal was filed after the
final hearing
and um did they accept the appeal
they accept the appeal so the appeal has
been was filed earlier you know
and so some we're hoping sometime this
fall will have the outcome of the appeal
okay
uh george you can weigh in here i i
would not do anything until that's over
well i'd hate for you to do you got
little ones involved
yes how old
uh
twins are six okay she's a ways man yep
um so yeah i
a worst case scenario would be you take
this money you put a down payment on a
place for you and the two little ones
and you start building a life and
suddenly come november some judge that
who knows what they're going to say
um you end up having to sell this house
and fork over some more money if
whatever who knows what's gonna happen i
don't get into the legal stuff but
i would if i'm you i'm just i can't give
you legal advice i just tell you just if
i'm in your exact same situation and my
two little kids and we're figuring out
i'm gonna live in an apartment and we're
gonna have a blast we're gonna play at
the park until this whole thing has a
period at the end of the sentence
yeah well that's kind of what i've been
thinking um because i was like there's
no there's no i i don't have a rush to
do anything right now but at the same
time too i was like oh you know
maybe i'm letting all the people the
history of the housing market get in my
mind even though i know
i'm less worried about the real estate
market i'm more worried about robert in
this situation and the family and so the
market's going to do what it's going to
do and you're debt free and you've got a
big pile of cash you're going to be all
right regardless of that the house you
wanted is 10 or 15 grand more than it
was a year ago so yeah i'm with john on
this we're pausing we're going to keep
renting until the smoke clears and then
with our new normal we're going to
decide all right we got 200 grand we're
going to get into a house how much money
is this
uh it's a little over a hundred grand
okay yeah cool i'm just gonna park that
in a high-yield savings account and let
it grow at one or two percent real
boring but it's gonna be the best thing
for you for you right now
all right now i did hear the other day
they were talking about
there was some
treasury bond or something like that i
could just
yeah no i wouldn't i wouldn't mess with
those you can only put like 10 grand in
a year and it's affected by inflation
and interest rates and so you're not
going to make you're going to make
pennies on that 100 grand by trying to
do the eye bonds and it's going to lock
your money up and if you sell them too
early there's penalties i wouldn't mess
with it man you'll be all right yep stay
flexible yeah that's right stay liquid
baby hey so okay
that's one of the worst brand new
sentence stay liquid baby that's yeah i
immediately regretted that as soon as i
left mine hey listen robert as long as
you lift never repeat that that's just
not gonna be good for your wisdom um hey
uh one of the ways that i uh in a
previous caller in in a uh in a recent
show um i
had a similar discussion um one of the
ways i try to stave off anxiety and i
try to stave off uh what comes next what
comes next is being busy
and trying to go out and solve and do
and do and solve and achieve and get and
solve
and so i really want to challenge you in
this season
okay this the smoke is cleared for all
intents and purposes right you kind of
know this is what it's going to be like
when something wild happens
um
focus on building a new planet that
doesn't have to do with um a home has to
do with your relationship with you and
your girls because they've been through
it right
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it's been a messy
couple years and so spend your energy
there man and make a piece have some fun
out at the parks and going fishing and
doing those things and um getting those
kids in first and second grade and focus
there and then when the smoke clears on
this thing then you'll be in a position
to say hey what comes what comes next
that'd be fantastic all right let's go
to ross in
boston what's up ross
what's going on thank you for taking my
call of course man what's up
so i just have a question so a little
bit of a back story so i am 27 i am a
traveling nurse um i've been listening
to the show for the past year i've read
dave's book
um and i've recently been able to pay
off my student my student loans my car
payment and all of my credit cards heck
yeah um now
without the debt thank you um now
without um the step that i have um i
have all this money now that i'm uh that
i am making and i don't know what i
should be putting it towards
this is a great problem so you were
throwing away at lenders and they're
like wait now it's with me what do i do
hot potato great so what are your future
goals are you renting right now do you
have a car that you like
um so
right now i am renting um i do have a
car that i have now but i don't have any
plans to purchase the car because i'm
enjoying not having a car payment
um so i'm just looking to see what i
should do with some money so right now
my financial situation is i've got
twenty five thousand dollars in this in
a savings account about fifteen thousand
dollars in an investment account um and
then about ten thousand dollars in a
401k okay so that 25k that's got to be
your emergency fund and maybe a little
extra
yes i am a big time saver so i just plan
to have about a year of a
a cushion i should say great well 27
with a great income like yours and you
have a fully funded emergency fund i'm
gonna be investing 15 percent of my
income you may be doing more than that
right now are you are you doing 15
yes i'm actually doing 15 to 20. aha all
right let's dial that back to 15. you're
27 you're gonna be a multi-millionaire
and we have other goals right now
because you don't own a home and so
let's start maybe saving up for a down
payment with every extra penny that's
coming in and maybe two three years from
now we can afford a place in boston and
it's probably gonna be like a condo
right
my brother's got a condo in boston and
it's insane it's like 300 square feet
and it's like and that'll be a million
dollars sir
so that would be my next goal for you
ross is uh home ownership and you know
with rent going up and up and up i'd
love for you to have a fixed rate
expense there with that mortgage and as
a 27 year old man you are hitting the
road and you're going to have all these
adventures there's going to come a
moment when you want your own place and
you want to settle down and start
getting some roots and so i love that
way to go paying off debt dude no wait
student loan forgiveness ross is just
getting it sometimes somebody says i'm a
travel nurse my first thought is you're
rich such a great kid awesome thank you
for your your commitment to our
communities we'll be right back
[Music]
so
[Music]
you know those moments when you're
sitting right next to someone but you
feel a thousand miles away from them
feels like a personal attack john it
kind of does but it's also true
some of you are feeling that way right
now like george
folks we've got to put our stupid phones
down
we've substituted deep and meaningful
conversations for binge watching netflix
and scrolling social media
you deserve better relationships and
that means having better conversations
and that's why i created questions for
humans these are conversation starters
that will help you
unplug from your screens and actually
connect and have fun with the people you
care about and here's the thing
i wish it wasn't the case it is and this
is the case in my house too
i have let the skill of just having fun
conversations atrophy because i haven't
had to do it for a decade now because i
just have a phone and we can text and we
can just send emojis and call it good
and our bodies are falling apart
we launched the first edition of these
cards a few uh months ago and they've
been flying off the shelves ever since
the first press sold out second press
sold out third press sold out and people
have been asking for more and more
topics and so we got the hint and we've
got new decks in and we've got new sets
of conversation cars cards we've added
girls night which i know a lot about
girls nights um guys night dating
parents and teens workplace addition
to the lineup and we also have
education ones now that are going to be
for elementary school middle school and
high school students for uses in
classrooms and in homes
all of them will get you spending time
laughing together learning something
unexpected and building deeper and
stronger relationships one of the most
common questions i hear george from
parents is i don't know how to talk to
my teenager i don't know how to talk to
my middle schooler i asked my
fifth grader hey how was school and said
fine it was fine and they go upstairs
they go stairs right or they just look
at their phone or they just stare off
into space out the window these cards
are designed to help you reconnect so
pick up one two or all of our new
questions for humans conversation
starters and start having fun together
and you can find all of them at
ramsaysolutions.com
can i pitch a new idea i'm all here it's
a podcast you
dave ramsey ken coleman and myself
we play girls night
questions for humans i think if dave
ever says i'm i'm through with the show
he's not one to go off gently into that
quiet night he's gonna want to just go
ahead and cancel all the way out so i
think he'd have 30 minutes of just
telling his deepest truest thoughts and
then we would play that and i think we
could officially wrap the show up i'm in
a slumber party by the way for girls
night we did go get some extraordinary
brilliant women of which we have plenty
of here across the board yes and they
are the ones that help direct those
questions because i am absolutely
unqualified all right let's go to kelly
in los angeles in l.a what's up kelly
hey guys how are you good how are you
good thanks um so my question is i live
in la i run my business remotely and i
own a house outright here um no payments
on it besides property taxes and
insurance and everything and i'm
very sick of the u.s and i'm going to go
travel for a year and i'm trying to
figure out
if it's in my best interest to
rent the house out and live off the
income from that while i'm gone or sell
it while the i mean the market's still
pretty high right now i'm here and
and put that money in like some kind of
etf or index and live off that instead
incredible well can i ask you how do you
have a paid for home in los angeles that
sounds like a pipe dream
um
i bought it off a family member a couple
years ago and they've had it for forever
so i got a really good deal on it
awesome way to go so what's the house
worth
it's probably about 1.8 1.9 oh so it's a
it's a two bedroom one bath i'm just
kidding
that's in the bad part of l.a
yeah
that's incredible so you have a paid for
1.9 million dollar property that you
could sell
i do yeah or you could rent it for how
much
probably
about like after property manager and
everything i'd probably be making profit
like 4 500 a month okay so here's how i
kind of look at it and deloney can jump
in so you'd make 50 grand while you
travel
and they deal with all the hassle or you
cash out today and take 2 million
i don't know i'm just looking at it just
based on no uh
so hard like you could
you could park the 2 million in an
online savings account and probably make
close to 50 grand
that's all i'm saying
yeah i'm scared that like
i'm worried that property values are
just going to go up and i'll get priced
out of the market and not be able to
come back if i want to are you going to
be okay regardless you have a paid for
home in la you're going to have 2
million dollars also people are the
population in california is going down
for the first time in history so
i'm not saying that the prices are going
to go down the values are going to go
down but i don't know that they're going
to appreciate wildly in 12 months and
kelly um i don't know if we if we
mention this you'll have 2 million
dollars
and a checking account like
i
i'm doing the napkin math forward what
is it what's the chances that you're
gonna move back to l.a
like you go away okay here's here's the
other things
um when somebody gets to a place where
they're like this and this maybe i'm
being serious now when they get to a
place where relationally i'm done
okay and so this isn't a boyfriend
you're walking away from for a year this
is america right i'm done with the u.s
i've got to get out of here i'm going to
go wherever
you don't know where the winds take you
when you
open up the sails out on the open sea
okay
what i would hate for you to do is to
get somewhere and say actually i want to
relocate here for a while make this a
couple of years make this three or four
years
and you still got this inc this property
it's much better to hit the road to be
out there and say ah i'm free
and i've got a two million dollar safety
net in a money market account somewhere
and
man that's a totally different
proposition for me so if you're my
friend or you're my sister i would say
dude sell your house be untethered
the world's greatest fallback plan
and the chances of you moving back to la
who knows what's gonna happen in a year
with you and your adventures right
yeah i know you're totally right kelly i
just did the the math here if even with
the 1.5 interest rate on that high yield
savings account you'd be making about 30
000
a year if you parked 1.9 million in
there
versus getting 50 but who knows if the
hvac goes out and needs repairs and
you're dealing with that while you're
traveling and you know eat pray loving i
don't know what what you're about to do
across the globe but i just don't want
to deal with that on this adventure is
kind of being a landlord even dealing
with property management they're
handling a lot of that but it sounds
like your heart's not in this property
anymore anyways
yeah that's that's probably true i mean
i've been fighting it but so you're not
going to be that excited to even come
back to it a year from now you're
probably going to be a different kelly
after this experience you might be a
texas kelly
you might be a florida kelly you might
be a yeah a new york killer who knows
there's something magical about being
untethered and having two million
dollars in the bank i don't know it's
true picture that in my head
and uh it's a great picture yeah it's a
fun picture i think i've made the
decision
i don't know the kelly house but i've
made it in my heart
i'm excited to travel
i'm
oh that maybe this may be
james you're asking us the other day to
like remember some of our favorite calls
this is going to be one of them
um do i want to
have kind of an anchor
um connected to a chain around my ankle
and make about fifty thousand dollars or
uh i just want to be in the south of
france and be like we're gonna do two
appetizers
i want the avocado toast uh because i
have two million dollars in my checking
account you can afford avocado toast
that's right the only heavy one of the
old only people yes and then you throw
in the gluten-free bread up charge are
you kidding me
but you know what i've got two million
dollars
i like this plan gluten-free me i'm in
i'm all in and i also like the idea of
getting out of california going to see
some stuff and then making some and
guess what if you want to live in
california again you have two million
dollars to go get you a place in
california hey everybody listening
though and all and george and i are
bogans of fun i think mostly because
we're both kind of jealous um 100
uh
this is why we do this
this is why you work so hard to be debt
free this is why you grind it and you
get through the baby steps this is why
you save money this is why you pay your
house off because then you have these
moments in life when we've talked to
people today george that husband just
announced i'm leaving i'm out of here um
or you get so frazzled and frustrated
with work with the news cycle with
whatever you say you know what i'm going
to france what australia for a year like
wherever you happen to find yourself
this is why we do this this is called
freedom and this is called
margin and bandwidth and options and
mean it's all lumped in there peace yes
hey george i do want you to know that
two million two million dollars is not
enough to cover the shame of eating
gluten-free avocados
james roasting me in the comments
section of real life
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five eight triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to trevor in
minnesota what's up trevor
hi john thanks for taking my call you
got it my brother what's up you guys
so i'll just give you a quick rundown
here before i ask my question um i'm 26
years old i've been working the baby
steps since december of 2020.
i've paid off 22 000 so far i have 45
left
um in that time i
paused the cash flow my wedding and
honeymoon that was a jeweler
last year i made 80 000 my new wife made
about 65.
my question is i'm going back to college
uh full time starting in august while
also working full-time i'm making a
drastic career change from law
enforcement i'm going into counseling
the estimated cost of that's going to be
about 50 000
and on top of that we are expecting our
first child in march
so i was just wondering what the best
course of action is going to be going
forward
as far as our finances and if we should
continue with the baby steps paying off
debt or if we should just stack money
away for
school and the birth of our baby
so when does school start
school starts end of august
whoa like a month from now
yep and you have 50 000 to throw at it
and cash flow it
no that is going to be about the the
total cost
okay so how many years is it four year
program
um it'll be three
three years left do you you have the
money to get through the first year
first semester first year
um we have enough to pay off the first
semester that's due in september okay
um
so
i grew up in the home of a policeman
i've spent my career working with
policemen
and i also have a degree in counseling
graduate degree okay so i've been there
for all the things you're talking about
please don't put yourself and your new
new um young child in the hole any
further by taking on debt to get through
this program okay okay it's uh i'd
rather see you take a semester that you
can pay for work another semester pay
for another like i'd rather you figure
it out that way or work your butt off
this semester to
impress your professors and show them
that you're all in
and be a great
student so they can give you some
scholarships give you a research
assistantship or something that will
help you with your tuition i'd rather
you do that than
wake up to be a counselor
to go help people and your experience as
a police officer is going to make you a
remarkable therapist you've seen some
stuff you've sat with a lot of people
you're going to be a gift
i don't want you going driving to that
job every day to help other people
burden by 40 000 in student loan debt
and a new baby okay
yep is that cool i know that's hard and
it's kind of dream bursty but please
make that a priority for you and your
wife i'd rather use i'd rather you see
you drag this program out and go four
years or five years then come out with a
whole bunch of debt
so yeah what that looks like in the baby
steps is pausing baby step two we're
saving up for the baby we're gonna make
sure we can cash flow this semester once
baby and mom are home safe we're gonna
look at the next semester making sure we
can cash flow that and once all the
money is there and you know you're gonna
get through school debt free then we can
start attacking those other debts you
have but until then you got a lot you
got some mountains ahead of you and so
it's okay to pause right now to make
sure that we can cash flow that and not
go further into debt
okay yeah so
you're saying basically
stack away cash get that fifty thousand
dollars saved up for approximately fifty
thousand and then go back to baby step
two and continue from there because that
leaves you still with your 14 000 you'll
be making minimum payments on those
right
yep okay
yeah and you don't have to save up all
50 000 you know by like we're saying but
as long as you can cash flow each
semester and the faster you can get it
stacked the faster we can get to the
debt and are you still going to be
working through school
yeah at least through the bachelor's
program and then the master's programs
one year which
at that time i'll have to resign
and just do the master's program full
time
well i mean i got through a phd in
counseling working full-time including
my practical man supervision and all
those things
so there's ways you can use ways to
figure it out um
uh so this is just like a three plus one
or a four plus one program
yeah it's a four plus one okay all right
so you're looking at about four or five
years of schooling anyway down just
checking it out
well i already have my associates okay
okay okay okay so you're just going and
taking your counseling classes and then
you're gonna start rolling in and taking
your graduate courses too
correct okay and then you will head off
and do your practicum and that where
this will get dicey is when you're doing
your supervision hours um depending on
where you find
um your
when you're getting your clinical hours
in so you can get your license that's
sometimes that gap that year to 18
months because some places require you
to pay them to do counseling for free so
they can supervise you
but sometimes you can find placements
where they pay you and that ends up
working out pretty well for you so yeah
very cool man
yeah you're you've got you're up against
it and but it sounds like you're all
doing all the right things to get you
where you want to go 5 10 15 years down
the road
you may not be able to progress as fast
as you want to go but don't go backwards
yeah absolutely don't go backwards thank
you so much for the call thank you for
loving your community both as a
dad and as a police officer and now as a
counselor such a great great gift all
right let's go to johnny in saint louis
what's up johnny
hey what's up y'all
we're just we're just getting it done
man how are you
same here same here hey guys uh quick
question um
i am debt free except for my
vehicle um i got
i got my thousand dollars set back i got
six months of expenses put back i got
about five thousand dollars in 401k what
should be my next step to
double hammer the car or what hold up
johnny i'm real confused you just said
you're doing the baby steps but now
you're saying you got your fully funded
emergency fund but you still have a
car loan
yes i got the car loan so you could pay
off the car loan today with the savings
uh
i got um
seven thousand so yeah and i have about
18 000 on it so you owe 18 000 on the
car and you have 7 000 in savings
right what's the car worth
uh right now the keller group look is a
little over 19 000. that's what it's
worth okay what's your income
about 40 000 a year whoo sell the car
that's a lot of car johnny johnny sell
the car
okay i mean how long is it going to take
making 40 to pay off the 18 100 years um
it's right now it's set for about 36
months i got 36 months left right
so three years of slowing your life down
not getting to do what you want to do
but you get to drive this car how nice
is this car uh it's a 2020 equinox
spring it's got no not even
15 000 miles on it okay i thought you're
going to impress me with the features
it's got heated seats baby well johnny
i've never heard
i don't want to run anybody down that's
not my thing but i've never heard
anybody be like what's up i got a brand
new equinox
no it's a nice car but uh you can get
another nice car they're out there so if
i'm you i'm i'm going to be debt free
today i'm going to sell the car you'll
have a thousand plus your seven thousand
let's go get you a five six thousand
dollar you know kind of beater car
that's what it is in this market and uh
then you'll have all of your income back
in your life and we can be about the
business of getting the emergency fund
in place three to six months followed by
upgrading in-car and johnny listen
by the end of this weekend you know what
you could be
dead free totally free i wasn't gonna
whisper it kind of creepy like george
just did but you're gonna be free man
free johnny is that better than a new
equinox
yeah yeah yeah that way i can work on my
retirement at 50 years old too there we
go now we're getting excited you're
going to be by sunday afternoon you've
sold this equinox you've bought yourself
another car it's not going to be pretty
at all but you're gonna be walking
taller you're gonna be about two inches
but johnny's gonna be able to retire
with dignity that's a fair trade yes
you're gonna be able to get to and fro
i'm excited for you man are you ready
i'm ready take the
excellent congratulations on taking a
step to freedom man there's something
about like yeah but it's new man
it's new
i just got it i just got it
i know and there's something about going
from a nicer car to a less nicer car
that just it hurts your price it's like
you're failing
but i care i care more about johnny's
future than his feelings right now and
i'm pumped about his future you should
tweet that out if i knew how twitter
worked i would tweet people still use
that i don't know i'll do it and see
here about your future instead of your
feelings i like that
well done we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is proverbs
18 15. an intelligent heart acquires
knowledge and the ear of the wise seeks
knowledge
albert einstein says learn from
yesterday live for today and hope for
tomorrow
the important thing is to not stop
questioning
i love that ask some good questions
that's fantastic all right hey george
hey john
uh new
york are you okay
i'm good okay you're breathing heavily
that got me worried i was just running
there sorry i thought you were upset
about this article no these uh it's rare
that i get to say these words i was
right and i continue to be right
um james brought us in this article here
that um this is a big news flash
everybody so if you're doing something
dangerous driving heavy machinery you're
going to want to park it for a second
because this is earth-shattering news i
hope someone is like on a tractor right
now he's going all right gotta park this
thing some guy's got a forklift and he
just sets all the stuff down he's like
hang on guys
hang on deloney's about to drop
something on us
um
article suggests
social media platforms like instagram
and tick tock are negatively impacting
users finances
as well as causing nearly half of
generation z and millennials to feel
unhappy about their financial situations
according to a recent study
those feelings include jealousy
inadequacy anxiety shame and anger
user spending habits are negatively
impacted as nearly half of users
admitted to making an impulse purchase
based on something they saw on social
media
most of them 64
saying they regretted them
additionally 64 of parents with children
under 18 on social media have reported
the online
platforms contributing to their kids
having unrealistic expectations about
money
i can't believe it took a study to get
here john
this is about the millionth study that's
come out and here's here's the
frustrating thing
whenever i'm talking to a parent and
they say the words
my
11 year olds addicted to i always stop
them
say they're 11.
they have no access to anything that you
don't allow to being put in front of
them
so unless they're in like uh the parents
are divorced and there's a uh you know
one parent is is just getting off the
rails
your kid's addicted to fill in the blank
chicken nuggets their ipad their iphone
the video games because you allow it
and so when a parent says 64 of parents
with children under 18 on social media
have reported the online platforms
contributing to their kids
not doing well
i just want to
pull my hair's short but i just want to
pull it out
because they're all it's like man i
handed my kid this thing
and their life is falling apart
man
it's just it's wild because
how did we not think that like staring
into a screen of other people's facade
of success would not cause us to make
terrible financial decisions and be
depressed and getting other children who
are not known for a their kindness to
one another b
making wise uh
discerning
judgments about the appearances of other
people let's give them an opportunity to
comment on how i look what i said how i
write how i speak how my teeth and hair
look how my money looks um and then you
partner that with very targeted
marketing that's listening to everything
you're saying and then saying hey you
can buy now pay later with one touch of
a button and all the boxes will show up
that will give you immediate happiness
billion dollar companies who have
partnered with neuroscientists to figure
out how to best manipulate your 16 14 13
11 10 year old into buying things
and then we just let it happen
parents take control back of your
children's minds please please
and i'll tell you as the parent of a
child who
[Music]
i i he's found himself on an island my
oldest because he's one of the very few
that doesn't have a phone
man i would love a group of folks to say
you know we're on the same team same
team john i got another tweet-worthy uh
line for you okay the problem
when you run other people's races is
that there is no finish line
yeah it's never enough you can't i'm
comparing well well he got a bigger
house than me and it's not fair because
like i feel like i work harder and like
i went to this better school and i got
this degree and why do they have all
this stuff now
you don't know their life you don't know
how deeply in debt they're in you don't
know if their marriage is falling apart
and yet we're scrolling going oh just
see how the delony's got a new look
look at the car he's driving he must be
doing very well the other night a couple
of buddies here from the office we went
up to a concert from a 90s band we
basically was like a karaoke night
and i have to admit i took five or six
photos of us just looking like we're
having a great time to get just the
right photo looking like we're having
just the right amount of fun and if you
look at it and say
yeah that's not a very good photo you
should have seen the other ones that i
deleted right we curate this world and
then we put it out for the for everyone
else to say look how much fun we're
having and i'm an adult and i fall for
it and i do have to call out producer
james was at that concert he was uh i
think he can vouch for the fact that it
was not a good time at the time of my
life it was a great time it was a little
bit awkward when he took his shirt off
and threw it into the crowd but other
than that that did feel a little bit
aggressive
it yeah but i mean james it's a great
point here's a good time what you don't
see is like the craziness and chaos of
the day the hard parts and again it's
hard to even capture that for social
media usually when you're taking a photo
it's to capture a highlight right but
the problem is when you have an entire
feed of highlights you have this very
unrealistic picture of what your life is
supposed to be like and the this this
quote says it best here in this article
you don't know if someone took a lot of
out a lot of debt to fund the amazing
vacation or the perfectly put together
outfit depicted in their photos you just
see the smile and the clothes with the
smile and the concert you think
everything's great you don't know what's
going on behind those scenes so
and on top of that if they paid cash
good for them and who cares sure keep
living your life way to go that's what i
love to if i see a nice car next may go
wonder if he paid cash wonder if he's in
debt and i go doesn't matter i'm just
going to keep driving look through my
windshield because that's how you don't
crash and john you have personal
experience with that
i was looking through the windshield i
just had my eyes closed all right let's
take a quick call out to therese in los
angeles california what's up terese hey
we're up against the clock so get right
to your question
yes my question is um
i'm wondering if i should um
refinance my house get some cash out
in order to renovate
and then rent my house out
and get that rental money as an income
and then my thought was to move to less
expensive area like a different state
would you rent in that area
no i'm gonna
my intention is to move to
a suburbs of uh
in georgia so how are you going to have
money to buy the house over there if you
haven't sold your current home
i wasn't going to buy i was going to
rent for a year okay and
and see you know if i like it there
number one
let me flip this around if you were
living in georgia
would you randomly take out a loan to
buy a rental property in los angeles
halfway across the country
you wouldn't you wouldn't
because you would be exhausting and you
wouldn't want to be a landlord 10 states
over and would you spend a bunch of
money to make your house nicer also that
you cannot enjoy it and someone else can
destroy it slowly
yeah you wouldn't killing me softly with
their touch you wouldn't want to do that
so here's what we're going gonna do uh
we would sell your house in los angeles
and then move to georgia i like renting
for a year when you move to a new state
but i would cut my ties and take the
money and buy yourself up like
rent for a year find the community that
you want to live in and then take some
time looking for a home and you're going
to have some cash how much how much
equity you have in your home
um probably
about 650 000 awesome that's gonna feel
good in a checking account you can
probably could you pay cash for a spot
in georgia with that kind of money
um yes
i love this plan how old are you
that's the thing i'm 69 and i'm a widow
and i'm um
uh
don't have any savings at all
so imagine going into your 70s with no
mortgage payment
and having some savings in the bank on
top of that and then we can actually
live our life and have a great
retirement or you buy a 300 000 condo
and you have 350 000
in a that you can sit down in a
retirement account now you're talking
about changing your whole life without
over complicating it with a scheme on
top of a scheme on top of a refinance on
top of a rental plan
let's go for simple and let's go for
peace as you're settling into the back
half of your life right good word hey i
want to thank everybody uh back there
running the booth austin
will
james kelly the whole gang george great
show appreciate it man fun times america
thank you so much for joining us be kind
to one another
and pay off your debts we'll see you
soon
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you